Grandma I can't do this
what's going on a little homework over
here yeah let's see if I can help
oh oh math that's not so hard
there are four of these ignore the
parentheses right why is this little two
so small it's it's weird you just don't
just go by the X the X means times so
that means
four times X2 what is double four
right excellent way to go nice oh
with that
this is a lot of credit card debt yeah
tell me about it
you know Janice my credit cards and
she's
using them as if I'm made of money she
thinks I'm a human ATM machine
okay 125 Amazon
oh best of Muppet Show on DVD classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
Blaster extreme that is by far the best
way to strengthen your core this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and you
twist it strengthens your entire core
your back core your arm core
your
the Marine Corps actually uses it I
think that's how they got core okay the
green bar is what you spend every month
on stuff you need like a car and a house
it's so cool I have my name at the top
the red bar is what you spend on
non-essentials like magazines
entertainment right things like that
this scary black bar
is what you spend on things that no one
ever ever needs like multiple magic sets
professional bass fishing equipment how
do you do this so fast is this
PowerPoint Michael I'm going to set you
and Jan up with a debt consolidator you
meet with this guy if we are going to
leave Jan out of this
she has to know we will find another way
we'll ask PowerPoint Michael this is a
presentation tool your presentation tool
if you think I'm going to tell Jan about
this I'm done no you're not okay just
you're not a tool look we'll tell her
that it's bad but it could have been a
lot worse but due to some fancy
Financial footwork I was able to cut it
in half
Jen is smart
Moses
do you know do I know what I think you
know no no what yeah no what does anyone
happen to know what fifty percent of 4
300 is 645 Michael's a genius right why
did you say dollars because that is how
my mind works what's 15 of 200
thank you this is from Hooters yeah it's
a business lunch
did not I don't need permission
you just got your corporate credit card
back you really want me to take it away
again it's ridiculous they took my card
away because I spent 80 bucks at a magic
shop what they don't understand is that
I bought the stuff to impress potential
clients so business related right I put
a cigarette through a freaking quarter
and you know what Toby they almost
bought from us
okay too fast everyone we need to pump
at a pace of 100 beats per minute oh
okay that's uh hard to keep track how
many is that per hour How's that gonna
help you I will divide and then count to
it right here are our final actual costs
for this year okay as you can see we did
pretty well so yes yes I can see
that we did indeed
why don't you explain this to me like I
am an eight-year-old all right well this
is the overall budget for this fiscal
year along
the x-axis yes there there's the x-axis
you can see clearly on this page that we
have a surplus of forty three hundred
dollars okay we have to spend that by
the end of the day or it will be
deducted from next year's budget
why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five
you know Mommy and Daddy give you ten
dollars
to open up a lemonade stand so you go
out and you buy cups and you buy lemons
and you buy sugar and now you find out
that it only costs you nine dollars oh
so you have an extra dollar yeah so you
can give that dollar back to Mommy and
Daddy but guess what next summer I'll be
six and you ask them for money they're
gonna give you nine dollars because
that's what they think it cost to
understand so what you want to do is
spend that Dollar on something now so
that your parents think that it costs
ten dollars to run the lemonade stand so
the Dollar's a surplus this is a surplus
we have to spend that forty three
hundred dollars by the end of the day or
it'll be deducted from next year's
budget
whoo we should spend this money on a new
copier which we desperately need okay
break it down in terms of well I I'm
okay I think I'm getting you
I hate disappointing just one person
and I really hate disappointing everyone
but I love Burlington Coat Factory
if you go in there with 645 dollars
you are literally a king
what did we learn this week well one
thanks to me
my team is much much faster coming to
decisions than I thought they would be
number two never buy a fur coat with a
credit card until you absolutely have
the money to pay for it
and three you should know that some
people think it's cool to throw buckets
of fake blood on you as you were walking
out of Burlington Coat Factory
rule number four in business image is
everything Andre Agassi
this car is an investment
right if I have to take out a client or
I'm seen around Scranton in it
I love it I love this car
do you like it
yeah how about this
I throw a corpse dress like me off of
the roof it hits the ground yeah the
head pops off this leads to me saying
the line I lost my head when I fell in
love with you that's a guarantee easy
enough to get a corpse just go to a med
school I already have the ring don't
think you need the corpse then there's a
ring
Holy Is that real yeah they say three
years salary
so um I forgot to tell you that I need
the car tonight oh um actually I need
the car why for Improv
well why don't you just pretend that you
have a car
good practice in case
your car you used to have two cars
traded them in now we're down to one
good economic sense
although the new cars are Porsche for
her
and then I just need you to sign here at
this era what kind of mortgage did you
get
uh tenure
well 10 over 30 so 30 year total what
what
you said 10.
10-year fixed
over 30 30-year total oh 30 years okay
okay wow you'll be paying this off in
your mid 70s all right
forget about retiring when you're 65.
hey I've got an idea you know that extra
bedroom if the whole girlfriend thing
never happens that's where the nurse can
live okay
yeah this is it whenever you're ready
yeah yeah
um
oh oh okay is that supposed to come off
hey look cool carpenter ants
um I'm gonna take a little uh breather
for a second excuse me
it'll be here waiting for you oh man
the ceilings are lower than they were
last week that I don't I don't know if
you showed me this same unit or not and
Michael this is the unit where are all
the hot people I was told that there
would be all these attractive singles
and as far as I can tell I'm the best
looking person here there's a basic
principle in real estate that you should
never be the best looking person in the
development
it's sort of common sense because if you
are
then
place to go but down
is this a financial thing if it's a
financial thing what some people do is
they rent out the third bedroom and
that's the next question I'm not going
to rent the third bedroom I want a price
reduction or I am a walk
you will lose seven thousand dollars if
you walk away right now
I made a right decision
I'm glad I find I'm a homeowner what
good to be a homeowner Diversified those
are good let me be clear there is simply
no money for anything other than a cake
and to develop a few more slides
although Toby won't be in them
I thought that you might say that
um
[Music]
every year my sweet sweet grandmother
sends me a check on my birthday for
fifty dollars and lately she has been
sending me like nine or ten checks a
year
as Nana
starts but
I knew I should be saving it for
something I just didn't know what I
should be saving it for
and then I had an Awakening Michael
my motorcycle
I put the money in my shoe
and I forgot about it until now
all right